welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and marvel's she-hulk has been
confirmed as tatiana maslany the
amazingly versatile actress from orphan
black and perry mason on hbo
and her cousin bruce banner's words i
see this is an absolute win
in allison brees words no
so the mcu officially now has its green
meaning you do not want to see across
from you in a courtroom
and with production for the disney plus
series reported to begin in february
it's now looking much clearer which
other marvel loose threads will tie into
this plot
i'm gonna break down everything we know
in spoiler warning in case i predict
anything too accurately so masalani is
an amazing talent both capable of
intense stunt work and transitioning in
and out of multiple identities skills
that eventually won her an emmy for
orphan
black and will probably win her awards
for perry mason these traits are going
to be
very important in her portrayal of
jennifer walters attorney and cousin to
bruce banner who in the comics gets shot
by mobsters and receives a last-minute
blood transfusion from her cousin bruce
which allows her to become she-hulk over
the decades she's become an
enormously popular character in the
comics a member of the avengers
delivering funny quips and innuendos but
unlike bruce jennifer walters tends to
stay in her hulked out form in her
everyday life continuing to work as an
attorney and defending high-profile
clients
and it's these details that clue us into
how marvel will likely introduce
she-hulk in her mcu disney plus series
probably dropping sometime in 2022. mark
ruffalo is reported to appear as bruce
banner in this series
and an avengers end game banner
explained how he achieved stasis between
the human
and the hulk form 18 months in the gamma
lab
i put the brains and the brawn together
and now look at me
now we've never really been given more
of an explanation of what he was doing
in those 18 months in the game of lab i
assume he was just like
standing in front of the collider
crossing his eyes and edging
until he got stuck as a half z with
fingers too fat for the keyboard
but i assume whatever process he used to
become smart hulk
will be the same process he uses to save
his cousin's life
like think about the only way he knows
to turn flesh into a rapidly
healing rigid form that can bounce back
from any injury
bombard her with gamma rays but in a
more controlled setting that he
developed during his months of research
during the blip years in end game
so that she stays in this form
permanently that will be how we get
she-hulk
jennifer walters just trying to continue
to live her life but due to her hulked
out form is constantly looked to
and sought after as an avenger like her
cousin is cat coiro was recently
announced as a director and executive
producer of the series with the head
writer and showrunner jessica gao
writer from rick and morty she actually
wrote the pickle rick episode so you
know she knows a thing or two about
heroes getting trapped in badass green
forms interestingly a ton of marvel
facebook properties are being written by
rick and morty writers mike waldron is
writing the latest draft of doctor
strange the multiverse
madness and his show runner on loki on
disney plus while jeff lovnis who wrote
last season's amazing bad of asset
episode is writing ant-man 3
recently announced to feature marvel's
new big bad kang the conqueror played by
jonathan majors so yeah most of the
future of the mcu
is in the hands of some of the most
talented rick and morty alums but anyway
walter's work as a defense attorney i
believe will be how the mcu ties in
other corners of the expanding marvel
universe when netflix canceled their
daredevil series in november 2018 that
began a two-year wait period before the
rights to the title would revert to
disney so that they could adapt the
character however they want unlike
disney plus or in some marvel film
production for she-hulk beginning just a
couple months after that wait period
expires
tells me we might see some kind of
crossover in this series
maybe some kind of legal collaboration
between jennifer walters and nelson and
murdock
let's just pray that kevin feige keeps
charlie cox as daredevil he's been so
good
and the same could be said for other
characters from the defenders universe
like punisher frank castle jessica jones
luke cage
characters i all think could be real
natural fits in a she-hulk legal
procedural but i think the
biggest supporting character to this
series literally will be a threat that
ties in she-hulk to other plot threads
from the upcoming mcu titles
red hulk you gotta look carefully
because these details could be hiding in
plain sight like i bet you didn't know
that i had
a ridge wallet in my hand because
actually i didn't it's on my head
thanks for playing thanks to the ridge
for sponsoring this episode the ridge
helps you carry what you need every day
from their flagship ridge wallet to
their portable charging commuter
backpack they want to make the most out
of what you're bringing with you
the ridge wallet is made out of
military-grade materials like titanium
or carbon fiber
it has a clean stylish design and we've
learned it as chainsaw proof
tested on our intern craig may he rest
in pieces
this is their forged carbon fiber wallet
they have other colors including some
very flashy tiki designs
it's light it's strong it's like a piece
of cone from coal mine
they make it easy to buy with free
shipping and free returns and a lifetime
guarantee it's got thirty thousand five
star reviews so you know they're doing
something right they also have great
backpacks and travel bags with rfid
blocking pockets optional device
charging batteries get 10
off today with free worldwide shipping
and returns by going to rich.com
new rockstars that's ridge.com new
rockstars and use the code
new rockstars find the link in the
video's description so red hulk is a
theory we've been keeping a
close eye on with thaddeus ross
returning to the mcu after his
appearances in civil war in infinity war
in a still mysterious role in black
widow pray we someday get to see this
[ __ ] movie but there have been some
rumors that some character from black
widow
will make a brief cameo in the upcoming
falcon winter soldier series
to set up a new marvel team and i think
that someone is thaddeus ross
recruiting the former captain america
foes that are gonna appear in that show
like zemo and based on some set reports
the return of batroc the leaper from
captain america winter soldier and
remembers that aaron kelly man might be
playing some version of songbird all to
form
ross's team of dark avengers that he
calls after himself
the thunderbolts and as the kind of nick
fury of that lineup
ross i believe will follow the path laid
out for him in the world warhol comics
and transform himself into
red hulk and that would be the threat
that jennifer walters she-hulk has to
face but i also don't think she'll be
doing it alone
could her cousin smart hulk take a
breath from those pancake rat bangers to
help her
i don't know that heavy breakfast seemed
to be slowing him down in endgame
hulk is not hulk just because he's plus
size and green he's hulk because he is
out of control his rage knows no bounds
i don't think we've seen that hulk since
like the first two avengers movies
overall the mcu has done him dirty like
he's been funny as a sidekick
but not the thunderclap and worldbreaker
comics have promised us
we have talked about some ways that
banner could rewind the clock on himself
for example the in-game quantum
entanglement scene when they
accidentally move time through scott
instead of scott through time
this this doesn't feel right what is it
that's
gone yes it's scott
it's baby it's scott as a baby he'll
grow
bring scott back time travel
i i see this as an absolute win now this
was an accident caused by a
misinterpretation of the epr paradox
and whatever specific control settings
that caused this screw up were likely
destroyed when thanos's ship crashed
through
the quantum tunnel and when thanos threw
his sword into the van
but if banner's makeshift quantum tunnel
that he used to send cap back in time at
the end of the movie could be rigged the
same way
without using tony stark's quantum
navigation wrist straps theoretically
banner could rewind time through his own
body
back to a younger stage of his life
before he spent those 18 months in the
gamma lab to become smart hulk or even
before he received any gamma radiation
back to just normal scientist bruce
banner now yes there is some debate over
whether making himself younger would
also undo that radiation but
based on the effects on scott i think it
would on
my back looks like what is it yeah so
scott aged into an old man
pulls his back suggesting that
physiological damage to the body over
time
including external forces like gravity
whiplash wear and tear causing back pain
as we age get added or subtracted
in that aging or de-aging process old
scott's wrinkles
are scars from gravity and yes from
solar radiation
on his skin reversed when he returned to
ageless paul rudd
so it logically follows that the same
process would also
undo the effect of various life events
like radiation
that resulted in banner's physical state
that my friends is how smart hulk could
restore his inner rage monster to help
his cousin fight
red meet ross so that she can get back
to scoring not guilty verdicts for
nelson murdoch and walters
or walters nelson murdoch discuss these
marvel theories with me on new
rockstar's official discord server by
becoming a patron at patreon.com
new rockstars subscribe to rockstars and
hit that notification bell follow me on
instagram
ea boss follow me rockstars thanks for
watching and for those of you who think
her name is tatiana miscellany whatever
i'm getting the pronunciation from her
when she was on jimmy kimmel and correct
me if i have this incorrect
tatiana maslany very good so shut up
[Music]
you